let's figure out the oxidation states
for some more constituent atoms in
molecules so let's say I had magnesium
magnesium oxide MgO I'll do oxygen in a
different color so what are going to be
their oxidation states and you might
know this already but let's look at the
periodic table because it never hurts to
get familiar with it so we have
magnesium magnesium has two valence
electrons it's a group two element it
would love to lose those two electrons
oxygen we already know is one of the
most electronegative atoms it's so
electronegative that oxidized has
essentially been named after them and we
know that oxygen loves to gain two
electrons so this is kind of a marriage
made in heaven this guy wants to lose
two electrons and this guy wants to gain
two electrons so what's going to happen
the the magnesium is going to lose two
electrons it was neutral so it's going
to have a plus two charge hypothetically
and then the oxygen is going to have a
minus 2 charge because it gained the two
electrons minus two so in this molecule
of magnesium oxide the oxidation state
of magnesium is plus two and the
oxidation state of the oxygen is minus
two now let's do a slightly a slightly
harder one let's say we had magnesium
magnesium let's say we have magnesium
hydroxide so hydroxide is o h2o h2o
right there where there's two hydroxide
groups in this so what are the oxidation
states good so my temptation would still
be look magnesium likes to glues its
electrons it's two electrons which would
make its charge positive it's
hypothetical oxidation state positive so
my temptation to say hey magnesium here
would be plus two so let me write that
there plus two and remember in order for
all my things to work everything to work
out if it's a neutral compound that all
of the oxidation states in it have to
add up to one so let's see if that's
going to work out now oxygen my impulse
is that it's oxidation state tends to be
minus two so let me write that down
minus two and hydrogen when it's bonded
with an oxygen remember in this case the
hydrogen's bonded with the oxygen first
and then that's bonded to the magnesium
so the hydrogen is bonded to an oxygen
hydrogen if it was bonded to a magnesium
you might want to say hey maybe it'll
take the electrons and it'll have a
negative oxidation state but when
hydrogen is bonded with oxygen it gives
up the electrons it gives up the
electrons it only has one electron to
give up so it has a plus one oxidation
state so let's see at first you might
say hey let's I'm adding up the
oxidation states plus two minus two zero
plus one I get a plus one oxidation
state here you know that doesn't make
sense Sal this is a neutral compound and
what you need to remember is oh no but
you have two of these hydroxides right
here so what you do is you figure out
the oxidation the the net the sum of the
oxidation states of the hydroxide so
that's minus two plus one so for the
entire hydroxide molecule you have a
minus one sum and then you have two of
them right you have two hydroxide
molecules here so the the contribution
to the entire compounds oxidation state
will be minus one for each hydroxide
then you have two of them so it's minus
two and then plus 2 from the magnesium
and your oxidation and it all adds up to
zero so that worked out now I want to do
a little bit of a side I want to go back
to doing some problems again but I want
to do a little bit of sidon on some of
my terminology because I've kind of used
oxidation state and oxidized and reduced
interchangeably to a certain degree but
it's say let's say you know we've done
so many problems with water Otto Otto
ionizing in two actually let me do two
moles of water and it's an equilibrium
with one mole of h3o plus plus o h minus
and obviously everything is in an
aqueous solution now let's look at the
water what are the oxidation states and
water right here well we've done this
already previous video oxidation state
of oxygen is minus two because it's
hogging the two electrons from the two
hydrogen's each hydrogen is giving up an
electron so it has an oxidation state of
plus one and we see this molecule
everything adds up because you have two
hydrogen's with the plus one so that's
plus two plus two minus two for that one
oxygen you get to zero and it's a
neutral compound now here what are the
oxidation states so one of these
hydrogen's left this one of these water
molecules without without and joined the
other of the water molecules without
taking its electron with it so it left
the electron over here so that oxygen
still has a minus two oxidation state
and this hydrogen still has a plus one
and that's why you do -2 plus 1 you get
minus 1 and this time it works out
because that's the actual charge on this
hydroxide ion now here what are the
oxidation states each of the hydrogen's
have a plus 1 have a plus 1 oxidation
state and then each and then this oxygen
has a minus 2 and so if you look at the
charge for the entire molecule plus 1 on
3 hydrogen so that's plus 3 you just I
just added them up - two so I should
have so plus 3 minus 2 I should have a
plus 1 charge on this entire molecule
which is the case now my question to you
is has any of the oxidation shaped
states changed for any of the atoms all
of the hydrogen's here I had and we
could call this you know two moles of
water or maybe I just had two molecules
of water but I have four hydrogen's here
right and all of them had an oxidation
state of 1 on the right hand side I have
4 hydrogen's all of them have an
oxidation state of 1 so although their
oxidation state is 1 in this reaction
and you can pick either direction of the
reaction hydrogen has not been oxidized
its oxidation state did not change its
it stayed its in maybe it was oxidized
in a previous reaction where the water
was formed but in this reaction it was
not oxidized likewise the oxygens we
have two oxygen molecules here or atoms
here each have a minus 2 oxidation state
here we have two oxygen molecule
each have a minus 2 oxidation state due
to this reaction at least the no
electrons change hands in our oxidation
state world so this is not an oxidation
or a reduction reaction and I'm going to
cover that in detail in the next video
and I just want to be clear that nothing
here was oxidized or reduced because
their oxidation numbers or their
oxidation states stayed the same and I
just want because you know sometimes I
look I'll say I'll say hey look
magnesium has an oxidation state of +2
oxygen oxygen has an oxidation state of
minus 2 magnesium was oxidized 2
electrons were taken away from it and
oxygen was reduced two electrons were
given to it and I'll say that implying
some reactions that produced it but
that's not always the case you know you
could have a reaction where that
necessarily didn't happen but the
oxidation state for magnesium is
definitely +2 and the oxidation and the
oxidation state for the oxygen or the
oxidation number is minus 2 but I think
you know what I'm talking about when I
say it was oxidized some at some point
it went from a neutral magnesium to a
positively charged magnesium by losing
two electrons so it got oxidized now
let's do some some harder problems so
hydrogen peroxide what I've said
multiple times already that oxygen tends
to tends to have a minus 2 oxidation
state this is minus 1 I think you see
the pattern this is plus well these guys
are plus 1 hydrogen is plus or minus 1
these guys are plus 2 I think you see
the pattern so whether you want to lose
or gain electrons so high you might say
well let's see water normally has a
minus 2 oxidation so you might be
tempted to do ok hydrogen it has plus 1
because it's bonding with water and
oxygen has a minus 2 but when you do
that you immediately have a conundrum
that this is a neutral molecule but you
have let's see 2 hydrogen's plus 2 2
oxygens at minus 2 minus 4 so this would
end up with a minus 4 total net
oxidation state with and that's not the
case because this doesn't have any
charge so like there's a conundrum here
and the conundrum is because if you
actually look at the structure of
hydrogen peroxide the oxygens are
actually bonded to
other that's where the peroxide comes
from and then each of those are bonded
to a hydrogen so in this case and this
especially in the first-year chemistry
course the peroxide molecules especially
hydrogen peroxide tends to be that one
special case there are others but this
is the one special case where oxygen
does not have a minus 2 oxidation state
let's look at this and try to figure out
what oxygens oxidation state would be in
hydrogen peroxide so in this case
hydrogen oxygen bond oxygen is going to
hog the electron and hydrogen is going
to lose it so it's going to have a plus
1 there same thing on this side
oxygen at least on this bond is going to
have a plus 1 it's going to gain an
electron what about from this other bond
with the other oxygen well there's no
reason why one oxygen should hog the
electron from the other oxygen so
there's not going to have any net impact
on its oxidation state so in this case
this oxygens oxidation state is plus 1
this oxidation this oxygens oxidation
state is also plus 1 so each of these
each of the hydrogen's have an oxidation
number of plus 1 each of the oxygens
have a oxidation number of minus 1 and
so you have a net of 0 2 x plus 1 plus 2
times minus 1 is 0 so that's just a
special case for it's a good one to be
familiar with let's do another one
iron 3 carbonate and now for the first
time I remember when we first
encountered iron 3 carbonate you
probably thought hey why is it called
iron 3 carbonate when there are only two
iron molecules here or two iron atoms
here and you're about to learn why let's
look at the oxidation numbers so oxygen
oxygens oxidation number tends to be -2
minus 2 now if carbon is bonding with
oxygen let's look at the periodic table
we have carbon bonding with oxygen
oxygen is carbon can go either way the
carbon you know sometimes it likes to
give away electrons sometimes it likes
to gain electrons when carbon is bonding
with oxygen this is the this right here
is the electron hog when if we had to
say who's taking the electrons it's
going to be oxygen right so carbon is
going to be giving away its electrons
but how many electrons can carbon give
away well let's see it has 1 2 3 4
valence electrons so the most it can
really do is give away four valence
electrons so let's go back to the
carbonate so the carbon can at most give
away its four valence electrons so what
will be the net oxidation number for the
carbonate molecule for the co3
so this is a +4 oxidation because it
only has 4 to give away if it's bonding
with oxygen is going to give them away
oxygen is more of a hog oxygen each
oxygen has a minus 2 so let's think
about it I have plus 4 minus 3 times
minus 2 right I have three oxygen
molecules so I have 4 minus 6 is equal
to minus 2 so we can kind of view it as
the oxidation number for the entire
carbonate molecule is minus 2
now if the oxidation if this the entire
carbonate molecule is minus 2 its
contribution to the oxidation state for
this entire c2 this whole kind of the
carbonate part of the molecule we have 3
carbonate molecules each of them is
contributing minus 2 so I have a minus 6
contribution if this is minus 6 and this
is a neutral molecule then our two irons
our 2 irons are also going to have to
have a plus 6 oxidation state because it
all has to add up to zero if these each
if this if both ions combined have a
plus 6 contribution to oxidation state
then each of the irons must have a +3
oxidation or that in our hypothetical
world if this happens
both at least three electrons are going
to favor the carbonate from each of the
irons so why is it called iron 3
carbonate I think you you may have
figured this out by now because this is
iron in its third oxidation state iron a
lot of the metals and especially lot of
the transition metals can have multiple
oxidation states when you have iron 3
carbonate you're literally saying this
is the third oxidation state or irons
oxidation number in this molecule will
be positive 3
now let's do another one this is
interesting acetic acid I think this is
the first time that I've actually shown
you the formal the formula for for a
acidic acid you have your ear well I
won't go into the whole organic
chemistry of it but let's try to figure
out what the different what the
different charges are or the different
oxidation states so we can just go look
if we just had this let's say sometimes
you'll just see it written like this
you'd say okay oxygens each of those are
going to have - two - two - two
hydrogen's are just going to have plus
one plus one plus one so how are we
doing so far we haven't include so these
oxygens are going to contribute minus
four and then the hydrogen's here you
have plus three and then here you have
plus one you add these up and you get to
zero and you're like oh so the carbons
must have no oxidation state they must
have an oxidation number of zero because
they're obviously I mean we're already
at zero if we just consider the
hydrogen's and the oxygens so let's look
at that and see if that's actually the
case you'll see so when when carbon is
bonding with hydrogen who's going to hog
the electrons when carbon is bonding
with hydrogen electronegativity as you
go to the right carbon is more
electronegative it likes to keep the
electrons or hog them than hydrogen so
hydrogen is going to lose the electrons
in our oxidation state world it's
obviously it's actually a covalent bond
but of course we know that when we're
dealing with oxidation states we pretend
that it's ionic so in this case your
hydrogen's are going to lose electrons
so they're just going to have an
oxidation state of plus one that's
consistent with what we know so far and
actually that's another thing you know
when I did this exercise right here I
immediately assumed oxygen the hydrogen
I mean has an oxidation state of plus
one I did that visit everything else in
the molecules carbon and oxygen which
are more electronegative than the
hydrogen so the hydrogen is going to go
into its plus one state if over here I
had a bunch of alkali and alkaline earth
metals I wouldn't be so sure I'd say oh
maybe hydrogen would take electrons from
them but anyway so these all gave an
electron to this carbon so just from
these hydrogen's that carbon would have
a
plus three sorry a minus three oxidation
state right these lost electrons this
guy gained three electrons so his charge
goes down by three the carbon-carbon
bond well there's no reason one carbon
should take electrons from another
carbon all carbons are created equal so
there should be no transfer here so this
carbons oxidation state is three now
what about on this side so we know that
oxygen and hydrogen this hydrogen is
going to have a plus 1 oxidation state
it's going to give its electron to this
oxygen this oxygen
like most oxygens are going to take up
two electrons one from the carbon from
this carbon and one from this hydrogen
so it's going to have a minus 2
oxidation state this oxygen is also
going to take 2 electrons in this case
both of them are going to be from this
orange carbon so it's going to have a
minus 2 oxidation state so what's the
oxidation state of this carbon it lost
two electrons to this guy of up here and
it lost it lost one electron to this
oxygen down here remember this guy got
one electron from the carbon and one
from the hydrogen so it lost one
electron here to there it lost three
electrons so in that reality it would
have a plus 3 charge so it turns out
that the average oxidation state in for
the carbon and acetic acid is zero
because if you average minus 3 and plus
3 you get to 0 and that's why I said oh
maybe these are zero but if you actually
write out their oxidation numbers this
green C has a minus 3 oxidation state
and this orange see this orange carbon
has a plus 3 oxidation state if you got
this one and I you know I don't think
it's overly complex you buy it you are
you will be a an oxidation state jocke
so I think you're all set now in the
next video we're going to start
exploring oxidation reduction reactions